[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hope you're enjoying your Super Bowl
viewing party here at the Caesars Palace
sports book on cabby Richards and this
is our betting insider Kelly Stewart you
know the game flows around even right
before kickoff and that narrative
continues it is a 10/10 tie and Super
Bowl 54
what are your thoughts so far cause then
it should be 13 nothing in or 13 10 and
I should have three field goals in the
bag referees didn't think so offensive
pass interference call a little ticky
tacky but here we are well how do you
feel about that Travis Kelce call or
George kettle call I mean wizard some
contact yes or contact on both sides as
always like I said it's a little ticky
tacky that's a second offensive pass
interference call that's gonna cost me
money in the last Oh 30 days so I'm not
very happy about it you think you'll
have residual effects in the second half
of this game
god I hope no we need two more field
goals cabby and we're gonna get there
I'm feeling good about my best bet for
today okay we're going to get to that
let's take a look at the second half
odds
it's a pick'em money line it's even at
minus 110 oh well it was minus 1 15 for
the Chiefs that's surprising to see it
change that quickly already okay and the
total twenty seven and a half are you
are you gonna lead towards any of these
cows for your second half wagering so
I'm virtually told you guys I liked the
game under under twenty seven and a half
is interesting I think both quarterbacks
are gonna really extend the field in the
second half I'm not gonna touch that
second half under but that is the way
I'm leaning towards here okay prop bets
make any viewing parties so much more
fun because everybody loves action on a
Superbowl Sunday so let's update you on
a few of the selected props offered here
at Caesar's Palace we should touched on
earlier at our show let's start with our
very own this is our Bleacher Report app
featuring rookie debo Samuels for the
San Francisco 49ers the lines reported
the game was over under 14 yards and you
see here
yikes Devo first touch just crushed my
hopes and dreams I'm glad this one got
bent down so I'm not shocked about it an
end arrived for 32 yards he had 39 yards
in the first half how impressed are you
by this rookie so far in the Super Bowl
Chad Johnson said it bass this man is an
absolute
he's just showing his rookie season and
he's not there trying to get that Super
Bowl ring all right speaking of which
let's go to the other side of the ball
Patrick with a home's last years MVP
making his first Super Bowl start
rushing okay the the line before the
game was 33 and a half over/under you
leaned under on that one right I did
actually bet this one under I told you I
thought it was about five yards too high
so sitting here at 11 right now I'm
feeling pretty good about this but as we
know it's always scared to back up
Patrick mahomes under so I'm not holding
my breath
just yet and running for the window to
cash the ticket okay let's go to one of
the receivers one of the features and
his feature receiver Tyriq Hill total
receptions this one is tricky man over
this is possibly terrible I mean he's
been getting double-teamed all game and
he had a couple of bobbles
ah man and he's got full receptions in
the first half yes and you put in for a
big second half from mr. Richard Sherman
maybe he can even pick one off and you
also hope that he that passion for homes
just prickle the ball to the other
receivers a little bit and he has been
honestly he has been spring with
everybody else I thought we'd see a
little bit more Kelsey than we have but
maybe Kelsey's actually the one getting
more double-teamed than this man right
here this was I think one of the most
fun props that we spoke about earlier
the scoring front the shortest TV is
Kelly's public or festive show to
sunshine she took the under one and a
half yards it was - 155 and it covered
Patrick mahomes on a little a little
rush I was a little disappointed they
didn't kick the fill ball on fourth down
because I would have loved to have been
in there with three field goals right
out of the gate but I don't think this
woman said and Casey fans will take that
touchdown and I love the patch of a
home's flex just the hottest big boy
walk afterwards and let's get to your
best bet Kelly
over/under three and a half field goals
you took the over we are sitting at
what's in that to sitting out to I was
really hoping to have that third one
right before a half we're gonna have to
slip this one but it's okay we've got
plus money coming in on it we'll get
three here in the middle of the third
quarter and be praying for a late one to
get that over three and a half earlier
in the week you participated in a props
best bet draft with matric nights and on
our social team here's what we stand at
halftime mattress Mack has a couple
coming in the first sack and then what
happens first OKC was a punt who else is
doing well our producer Greg got that
College juice check over on a patent on
our touchdown yeah where you sitting
tell us I'm over here but Sam looks
really good he took the BR out the PR
prop bet and the first time now I mean
he just met some ridiculous stuff so
he's looking really good and as you went
your mattress Mac two for two so far
forget we're gonna get this over three
field balls potential homes we'll throw
one and hopefully we get Jimmy G and
this moster one's looking pretty good he
was some kind of absence
we'll call him in the first half
hopefully they put tap and Coleman back
in there to get a few more rushing yards
and maybe we're a team sits a little
more longer on the bed
listen buckle up for a second sick
buckle up for the second now it's gonna
be a wild one I can't even talk cause
I'm excited because a Superbowl halftime
shows on and choice to go 54 this has
been a special Super Bowl edition of a
be our bedding show it has been
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book remember to follow us on social at
BR underscore betting for your chance to
win free merch Allen to all those that
already got their free merch from our BR
prop bet and good luck to on all of your
Superbowl bets and here is to a
profitable second half there's good luck
everybody
[Music]